olic deux frères aventuriers ont décidé
de suivre le cours du troisième plus
grand fleuve du monde
les yankees notre objectif est simple
aller à la rencontre d'un fleuve
mythique qui telle une artère irrigue le
pays le plus peuplé au monde
[Musique]
en cinq mois de sa source sur les hauts
plateaux tibétains à son embouchure à
shanghai ils ont parcouru plus de 7000
km à moto et en tricycle à la découverte
du lien qui unit l'homme à l'eau
[Musique]
nous filons à toute allure vers de
nouvelles rencontres et des paysages qui
sans aucun doute compte encore beaucoup
nous surprendre bordel tu as rien à
faire ici avec son chariot
[Musique]
c'est votre avis
amis
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur rt france pour 1h30 d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
une émission essentiellement consacrée à
la crise du coronavirus en france et
dans le monde
le premier ministre et le ministre de la
santé questionné en fin d'après midi
dans le cadre de la mission
d'information sur la gestion de la crise
du coc vide 19
il est probable que le déconfinement
france ne se passe pas en une fois et
pour tout le monde avec l'art edouard
philippe
alors que les hôpitaux d'île de france
arrive à saturation
trente six malades sont arrivés en
bretagne par tgv 100 autres vont être
transférés d'ici jeudi midi dans le
monde le nombre de morts a doublé selon
l' oms le corona virus a tué plus de
quarante quatre mille personnes dont les
trois quarts en europe la pandémie
qualifié par l'onu de pire crise pour
l'humanité depuis 1945 aux états unis
donald trump change de ton et évoque des
prochaines semaines
très douloureuse pour les américains
elles selon les projections de la maison
blanche l'épidémie pourrait faire
jusqu'à 240 mille morts dans le pays un
avion russe avec du matériel médical
doit atterrir à new york dans les
prochaines heures
[Musique]
une pénurie de médicaments c'est ce que
redoute neuf hôpitaux européens qui tire
la sonnette d'alarmé dans une lettre
adressée à leurs gouvernements
respectifs
il appelle à des mesures d'urgence
craignant le manque de curare de
corticoïdes ou d'antibiotiques
alors que la demande de médicaments
utilisés en réanimation explose en
pleine crise sanitaire d'une ampleur
inédite
[Musique]
on dénombre en france 450 patients de
plus en réanimation ces dernières 24
heures selon le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand comme chaque soir jérôme
salomon le directeur de la générale de
la santé a fait un point sur la pandémie
qui secoue le pays et ces dernières 24
heures la france comptabilise la 4032
mort soit 509 de plus par rapport à hier
avec 411 ehpad du grand est sont touchés
par le coronavirus sur les 620 que
compte la région est 570 personnes sont
décédées dans les ehpad de cette région
sans que l'on sache la proportion de
celles morte du pô ville
alors que les hôpitaux d'ile-de-france
sont saturés 1 36 patients graves de la
région parisienne sont arrivés en
bretagne par tgv médicalisé selon jll
agences régionales de santé sont malades
supplémentaires vont être transférés
d'ici jeudi à midi et pour répondre à la
saturation de ses hôpitaux à descendre
commis 19 voit le jour dans l'hexagone
nos équipes sont allées dans le var à la
rencontre de médecins libéraux et
infirmiers ils reçoivent et s'occupe de
patients inquiets des centres devenu un
lieu précieux entre hôpitaux et urgences
reportage d'isabelle ferrières et walid
bennani une école maternelle transformés
en centres de consultation à la
seyne-sur-mer une trentaine de patients
choisissent chaque jour cet
établissement pour se rassurer et
parfois se faire dépister
sourira est venu accompagner son père
fatigué ces derniers jours et qui se
plaint de courbatures les deux sont dans
un premier temps pris en charge par une
infirmière
toutes les questions sont bons à poser
en cette période d'épidémie
quand est-ce qu'ils ont eu de la fièvre
des frissons découvert des courbatures
de la toux s'ils ont des nausées de la
diarrhée
si ils ont été s'ils ont mal au ventre
s'ils ont des douleurs thoraciques six
ans perdu le goût s'ils ont perdu
l'odorat
on leur demande s'ils ont des centres
des antécédents cardiaques respiratoires
s'ils ont du diabète s'ils ont eu un
cancer s'ils prennent un traitement bien
sûr j'ai oublié de dire quand on
l'accueille bien sûr on lui met un
masque on lui fait des insectes et les
mains et on lui met une paire de gants
aucun risque n'est pris pour le patient
et le personnel médical
le matériel est livré par des
industriels et laboratoires proches
après les questions place aux premiers
examens
prise de température tension calcul de
la fréquence respiratoire avant de
basculer dans le bureau du médecin
généraliste
les gens qui viennent ici peu pourrait
aller à l'hôpital donc c'est toujours ça
qui n'ira pas l'hôpital et qui
encombrent aura pas les urgences dans la
mesure où sont des gens qui sont
validées qui sont pas urgents en fait on
de noter piste aujourd'hui que les gens
qui ont une maladie chronique et qui qui
rentrent dans les critères de dépistage
aujourd'hui c'est pas tout venant c'est
à dire on peut pas dépister des gens qui
sont jeunes en bonne santé on va
déguster que ceux qui ont une maladie
chronique
seul le médecin prend la décision de
dépister ou non le patient pour moi med
diabétiques avec des problèmes
récurrents au coeur un test est
nécessaire il se plie donc aux consignes
des infirmières trois sont présentes du
lundi au vendredi au sein de ce centre
qu'ovide 19 ainsi que trois médecins
libéraux et une coordinatrice pour la
moitié des effectifs
il s'agit de volontariat bon je trouve
que c'est très très bien au moins ça dès
les encore jeu
à l'hôpital et c'est très très bonne
initiative du maire manière à elle comme
elle vit avec mon père donc voilà donc
elle est une personne à risque et les
cardiaques
elle a subi plusieurs opérations cette
année donc ça fait qu'on a un peu peur
pour elle aussi
donc voilà donc là je compte là on l'a
ramené demain pour qu'ils se fassent
dépister
après le passage au centre les patients
sont suivis soit par téléconsultation
soit par un infirmier qui leur rend
visite tous les deux jours pour l'heure
une trentaine de tests sont effectués
par semaine dans ce centre qu'ovide 19
et dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
le premier ministre edouard philippe et
le ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
ont été auditionnées dans le cadre d'une
mission d'information de l'assemblée
nationale des auditions par
visioconférence avec une quarantaine de
députés a pour plus de précision va
retrouver devant l'assemblée nationale
notre reporter mona hamou dès lors un
mona bonjour alors expliquez nous quels
sont les enjeux cette mission
d'information et qu'est ce que l'on peut
déjà en retenir
voilà alors petit problème technique on
vous retrouvera plus tard mona amoud et
l'or mais pour revenir sains sur cette
mission d'information de l'assemblée sur
le co vide 19
nous sommes avec sébastien chenu porte
parole du rassemblement national député
de la 19e circonscription du nord
sébastien chenu merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer à cette audition du premier
ministre et du ministre de la santé sur
la gestion de la crise du coronavirus
vous saluer cette initiative
oui et elle est pas mal de crise
la démocratie doit continuer mais
surtout je note la question
d'information n'a pas associer les élus
du rassemblement national
nous en sommes exclus aucun député du
rassemblement national ne fait partie de
cette mission d'information et par
conséquent tu nous ne pouvons pas poser
les questions que se posent à travers
nous finalement des millions de français
donc ce service qui dit bonne que chez
le gouvernement
pas de quoi en être très satisfaits
puisque l'opposition la principale force
d'opposition
et encore une fois pris de parole
question vous les posez on va y revenir
à mes avants parmi les déclarations à ce
soir à retenir est celle du
déconfinement il est probable qu'il ne
se fasse pas en une fois pour le prix
pour tout le monde selon le premier
ministre ces d'une sage perspective
qu'est ce que vous proposez vous de
votre côté nous ce que nous proposons
est que l'ensemble des français ou en
tous les cas un grand nombre de français
au premier rang desquels les soignants
c'est à dire les personnels hospitaliers
mais pas seulement également les
médecins les infirmiers libéraux et même
les auxiliaires de vie tu le plus grand
nombre possible de français soit testé
avant d'être des confiné la réalité
c'est que c'est politique de
déconfinement dont on imagine qu'elle ne
va pas se faire en une fois on n'appuie
pas sur un bouton home ou sur un bouton
on off pour mettre à l'arrêt ou en
marche un pays elle ne peut se faire
qu'à partir du moment où on sait qu'ils
sont les français qui sont affectés ou
immunité 10 à 10,2 cette maladie et par
conséquent il faut des tests par
conséquent il faut pour pouvoir tester
le plus grand nombre possible de
personnes lire les verts se
déconfinement la logique étant si vous
êtes malade vous restez en confirmant
que cette soigner dans les services
adaptés ou chez vendre ou à l'hôpital si
votre cadeau excessif
il vous n'êtes pas malade si vous êtes
immunisés vous pouvez reprendre une
activité normale petit à petit et bien
pour cela il faut des centaines de
milliers de tests et lorsque j'entends
que le gouvernement socialiste est de
serre tester khalil personnes on est
très loin de ce que chose d'ailleurs les
allemands mais très loin du compte -
déconfinement qu'on pourrait imaginer
qu'on pourrait espérer surtout les prix
proche possible dans ce cas là et sur la
question du tracking qui a été évoquée
également c'est à dire la possibilité de
localiser
les habitants de plusieurs manières le
gouvernement a dit que c'était une piste
à étudier vous en pensez quoi vous mais
je ne comprends pas bien l'utilité de
cette piste à partir du moment où on ne
teste pas les français en parallèle et
j'allais dire même avant de mettre en
place ce tracking qui est quand même
source que d'interrogations qui concerne
les libertés individuelles des pays qui
l'ont très long c'est en parallèle d'une
politique de tests qui permettaient
ensuite peut-être de rendre utile ce
dispositif pour l'instant je ne vois pas
ce que ça apporterait elle de pouvoir
savoir où les français vont si on ne
devait peuvent pas testé ça n'a aucun
intérêt réel
je pense que si ce n'est pas couplée à
une politique de test tout ceci est bien
il donnera lieu à des réserves
importantes en tous les cas également
des interrogations concernant les
libertés individuelles faut pas pourquoi
on permettrait finalement a honte c'est
trop petit derrière l'état de disposer
de données personnelles à partir du
moment où tu n'aurais pas testé
l'ensemble de la population
autre phrase à retenir ce soir salle
d'edouard philippe je le cite
nous ne savons pas tout at il concédé
comment est-ce que vous recevez cette
déclaration du premier ministre
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
deux c'est pas tout ça c'est une
évidence on va pas lui faire le procès
de ne pas tout savoir
le problème c'est qu'il n'a pas anticipé
peut-être deux côtés c'est un vaste
débat que celui de la chloroquine il est
peut être deux côtés des avancées
possibles je peux regarder je considère
que le gouvernement n'a pas anticipé
il a un style ise et il a menti aux
français sur ce lot de larmes et qui
sont objectives chaque chose et on
trouve un habile infantiliser les
français en leur disant qu'il n'y aurait
que 15 ordres de confinement alors qu'on
savait et il départ qu'il y en aurait
bien plu il a menti en disant que les
masques de servair rien il a raconté
n'importe quoi en disant français qu'il
fallait continuer à sortir à aller voter
qui n'a pas été à la hauteur c'est moins
confuse elle n'a pas anticipé et stocks
de masques depuis bien longtemps
d'ailleurs ces prêts
et ses soeurs républicains et
socialistes bertrand madame touraine
devront venir nous raconter ce qu'ils
ont fait aussi des piquets et bien on
pas été à la hauteur
ce sont tout simplement les conséquences
de la politique qu'il mène
c'est à dire moins d'état pas d' état
stratège la déconstruction finalement de
l'état ans dans tous ces domaines
aujourd'hui on paye très cher ses
conséquences est bien là devant
aujourd'hui devrait peut-être être un
peu plus attentifs aux recommandations
de son l'opposition je crois pouvoir
dire que marine le pen avec les premiers
leaders politiques nationales bien avant
les autres a donné des voix des
propositions des possibilités offertes
seront faire face à cette crise elle n'a
pas été suivie
on va à ricaner nationale lorsque nous
disons qu'il fallait contrôler les
frontières lorsque nous disions qu'il
fallait relocaliser la production de
masques en france etc etc
nous avons été tournées en dérision
aujourd'hui nous considérons qu'il faut
tester un le plus grand nombre possible
de trancher nous considérons une loi qui
permettra de déconfinement nous
considérons aussi il faut donner
probablement du crédit à différents
chercheurs dont le professeur out qui
semblent être frappés d'ostracisme
je raconte nous explique pourquoi alors
pour conclure ces bassins chenu les
députés communistes eux envisagent de
lancer leur propre commission denquête
un juge dans le champ de la mission
d'information trop vaste est-ce que
c'est également envisagée par votre
parti nous n'avons pas les moyens de
lancer une mission d'information puisque
n'a pas de député
et alors ils ce sont les groupes qui
peuvent le faire mais il est des banques
et les premiers ministres président de
la république madame bil'in et puis il
est prêté cette heure je parlais de
super temps vannes tout raide un mail
ils sont incapables d'outré monsieur
véran devront venir rendre des comptes
de dire nous expliquer les raisons qui
les ont amenées à mener des politiques
qui ont exposé les français à fait
dangereux et en tous les cas ne pas les
protéger expliqué pourquoi ils ont
accepté des données des délocalisations
d'entreprises qui fabriquait des masques
pourquoi ils ont accepté de faire le
tenir les élections municipales
oui il y aura beaucoup tant réécrire
l'histoire tu es français demanderont
des comptes il faudra en tirer un
certain nombre
conséquence dans les politiques qui
seront menées merci beaucoup sébastien
chenu d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes porte parole du
rassemblement national et député de la
19e circonscription du nord et on va
tout de suite retrouvé devant
l'assemblée nationale notre reporter
mona a boudé lors mona alors expliquez
nous quels sont les enjeux 1 de cette
mission d'information qu'est ce qu'il
faut déjà en retenir
alors cette mission informative elle a
pour but de contrôler les décisions de
l'exécutif prises pendant cette crise
sanitaire les députés de tous les bords
étaient présents pour poser leurs
questions mais par visio conférence
plusieurs députés ont posé des questions
sur différents thèmes que nous
aborderons un peu plus tard en tout cas
tout au long de cette mission
informative olivier avérant le ministre
de la santé et edouard philippe le
premier ministre ont répété à plusieurs
reprises le caractère grave de la
situation que traverse notre pays c'est
une crise mondiale sans précédent et la
situation est extrêmement grave ce sont
leurs mots qui l'ont répété à plusieurs
reprises lors de cette mission
informative et une des premières
questions et c'est peut-être la question
que se posent tous les français jusqu'à
quand va durer ce confinement edouard
philippe a parlé de déconfinement
plusieurs scénarios sont à l'étude
d'après le premier ministre mais pour
l'instant aucune certitude puisque la
situation change chaque jour je vous
propose de l'écouter
ce qui est à peu près acquis à ce stade
c'est que nous avons décidé du
confinement en application d'une
stratégie que le ministre et moi-même
avons plusieurs fois expliqué qui
consiste à limiter le nombre de cas
sévères en essayant de faire en sorte
qu'ils ne dépassent pas les places
disponibles d'accueil dans les services
de soins intensifs et réanimation
cet indicateur aussi longtemps qu'il n'y
a pas de traitement prouver pas de
vaccin reste évidemment un indicateur
décisif pour le déconfinement il est
donc probable jeudi probable et j'essaie
d'être précis dans mes mots probable que
nous ne nous acheminons pas vers un
déconfinement qui serait générale et
absolue en une fois partout et pour tout
le monde
lors de cette mission informatif qui est
toujours en cours d'ailleurs les
questions sanitaires se sont dirigés
naturellement vert olive et veyran le
ministre de la santé qui a fait un
récapitulatif de la situation plusieurs
questions ont été posées concernant
l'acheminement être démasqué le manque
de moyens cruels dans à certains
hôpitaux
le ministre de la santé a voulu se
montrer rassurant il a donné quelques
chiffres
il a dit que 40 1 millions de masques
étaient utilisés à par semaine en france
et un milliard de masques avait était
commandée il explique que les mesures
prises sont exceptionnelles je vous
propose à de l'écouté
cette semaine pour vous donner une
indication nous avons renforcé notre
stock de l'ordre de 28 millions de
masques donc nous avons consommé 40
millions et fait rentrer 28 millions de
masques 8 millions par une production
nationale
le reste relevant de dons et
d'importation le plan blanc qui a été
activée très tôt la déprogrammation de
toutes les activités dans les hôpitaux
et les cliniques privées a permis
d'augmenter nos capacités de réanimation
à dix mille lits et nous sommes en train
de continuer les augmenter avec un
effort phénoménal vous l'avez compris
est cette mission informative elle aura
lieu chaque mercredi ou le gouvernement
devra rendre à des comptes à la levée de
ce confinement cette mission informative
et bien
transformera en commission parlementaire
ils feront une enquête par la suite
c'est une demande à des républicains
merci mona hamou dès lors en direct
devant l'assemblée nationale
traitement controversé elle hydroxyque
laurie keane va faire l'objet d'une
étude lancée par le chu d'angers est
suivi 32 par 32 autres hôpitaux français
l'étude aura pour objectif de mesurer
les effets du traitement sur le colis de
elle concernera 1300 patients
volontaires sur l'ensemble du territoire
a les résultats annoncés dans les
prochaines semaines pourront alors
établir avec certitude à l'efficacité ou
non du traitement et pour parler de
cette étude d'envergure nationale sur
l'hydrocarbure rockin mené par le chu
d'angers nous sommes avec le docteur
laurent alexandre entrepreneur et
essayiste docteur laurent alexandre
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors cette étude 1 menée
par le chu d'angers
c'est une façon de clore définitivement
le débat sur l'hydrologie chloroquine il
devenait évident qu'une telle étude soit
menée
oui maintenant il faut réaliser des
études aux standards internationaux
nous ne pouvons plus faire des études
bâclé avec des méthodes statistiques qui
ne sont pas acceptables donc l'étude
danger comme l'étude discovery sont des
études qui vont permettre de trancher la
question de la chloroquine nous allons
enfin pouvoir déterminer si la
chloroquine aggrave les malades les
améliore ou n'a pas d'efficacité selon
vous à quel moment on pourra avoir des
résultats fiables de cette étude on va
avoir des résultats intermédiaires mais
ce ne seront pas des résultats
définitifs
normalement discovery et puis l'étude
d'angers vont commencer à donner des
résultats entre quinze jours et trois
semaines
ce seront des résultats intermédiaires
qui n'auront pas une validité
statistiques absolue mais qui donneront
des indications il va falloir attendre
plus de temps pour avoir une certitude
statistique
sauf si l'effet de la chloroquine était
exceptionnel auquel cas on pourrait voir
relativement rapidement les faits lors
de cet essai clinique sur un nombre
important de malades 1300 quand même
même si c'est un peu moins que
les sept discovery alors cette hypothèse
de la chloroquine c'est le professeur
raoul vincke ya commencé à en parler il
est pour vous le connaissiez bien vous
l'avenir yémen mais aujourd'hui plus du
tout pourquoi on moi je suis un grand
fan un grand admirateur de didier raoul
t je suis profondément déçu je me sens
trahi par la mauvaise qualité des études
qu'il a fait il à hystériser le débat
quand je vois la différence entre la
belgique jeu je viens bruxelles et la
france l'hystérie autour de la cure au
kiné et du traitement de cette maladie
en france alors qu'en belgique nous
avons l'union nationale et où tout le
monde est d'accord sur la stratégie
camillo au point le gouvernement belge
je suis affolé on est quasiment dans une
guerre civile médicale en france et
didier raoul tu as contribué à ça en
donnant des faux espoirs et en faisant
croire que il avait tranché la question
ce qui n'est pas le cas parce qu'ici la
chloroquine donné des résultats et demi
sans ça se verrait une très large partie
des new yorkais prennent de la
chloroquine et comme vous avez pu le
constater il y à un ballet ininterrompu
de cercueil qui sortent des hôpitaux new
yorkais donc il n'ya pas de médicaments
miracles
bill gates lui-même a incité à la
prudence et à continuer les recherches
il n'y aura en réalité pas de traitement
miracle il n'y aura pas de traitements
rapidement il va falloir des mois et des
mois et des mois de recherches
scientifiques très rigoureuse et
complexe pour arriver à trouver des
thérapeutiques donc aujourd'hui il faut
faire attention à ne pas donner de faux
espoirs
parce que la réaction des français
pourrait être terrible
s'ils sont demain déçu donc il faut être
prudent attendre le résultat de l'étude
discovery et de la belle étude qui est
en train d'être réalisés selon les
standards scientifiques internationaux
au chu d'angers
et en attendant il faut faire attention
à ne pas raconter n'importe quoi la
science ne se fait pas sur les plateaux
de télévision
elle se fait avec des méthodes
statistiques des méthodes scientifiques
irréprochable ce qui n'est pas le cas
hélas jusqu'à maintenant mais c'est en
train de changer avec l'étude discovery
et l'étude du chu d'angers
dans la situation d'urgence dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons
bon dans la situation de guerre 1 pour
reprendre les mots du président eh bien
certains disent on n'a pas le temps de
respecter le protocole habituel
alors pourquoi pas finalement ne pas se
baser sur le travail du professeur out à
grande échelle qu'est ce que vous
répondez oui mais eux vous commettez une
erreur on fait l'hypothèse que soit la
chloroquine et inefficace soit elle est
efficace mais il ya une troisième
possibilité c'est qu'elle aggrave les
malades parce qu'on sait très bien que
la chloroquine a parfois des effets
paradoxaux
c'est à dire qu'elle n'agit pas de la
même façon en éprouvettes et chez les
malades
si on prend le chikungunya est bien la
chloroquine tu le virus quand il est en
éprouvette en revanche elle aggrave
l'état des malades
il ne faudrait pas qu'il se passe la
même chose avec le virus du coc vide 19
il ne faudrait pas qu'on a une
efficacité en éprouvette mais qu'en fait
les malades et un taux de mortalité
supérieure avec la chloroquine que sans
chloroquine comme 98 % des malades
guérissent spontanément il faut faire
attention à ne pas passer à 97 ou 96%
dans l'hypothèse où la chloroquine
aggravait l'état des patients
or l'état actuel des études ne permet
pas d'éliminer cette hypothèse il est
possible que la chloroquine et un petit
effet il est possible qu'elle n'ait pas
d'effets et il est possible qu'elle ait
un effet négatif
nous devons donc être prudent parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de preuve de
l'efficacité de la chloroquine s'il y
avait une preuve de l'efficacité de la
chloroquine je peux vous dire que je
conseillerai immédiatement qu'on la
donne à tout le monde mais ça n'est pas
le cas nous avons déjà vu des
médicaments contre des virus qui
augmentait la mortalité des malades par
rapport à l'absence de traitement donc
soyons prudents on peut en donner en
compassionnel aux malades mais en
faisant attention et il faut cesser de
faire croire que ces traitements miracle
il faut cesser de faire croire que c'est
un traitement qui marche dans 100% des
cas nous devons maintenant être très
humble très modeste nous nous sommes
tous trompés sur la dynamique de cette
de cette épidémie personnellement en
janvier gelé complètement sous-estimé
je me suis vautré comme tout le monde
comme d'ailleurs didier raoul tu
souvenez vous il y a encore la vidéo sur
youtube disponibles didier raoult nous
disait que le coronavirus faisaient
moins de morts que la trottinette
donc nous nous sommes tous trompés il
faut maintenant faire attention il faut
respecter les protocoles selon les les
les méthodes scientifiques
internationalement reconnu
il faut pas donner de faux espoirs il
faut être prudent c'est un combat qui va
être très très long donc il faut que les
français ne soient pas déçus par les
faux espoirs et comprennent que la
science va avancer doucement parce que
ya pas de solution magique trouver un
remède contre ce virus va prendre
probablement beaucoup de temps je pense
qu'il y à moins d'une chance sur cent
qu'on ait un traitement vraiment
efficace avant les vacances d'été et je
le regrette je ne dis pas ça de gaieté
de coeur
c'est une constatation mais aujourd'hui
on n'a pas de bons résultats avec les
médicaments anti hezbollah dans les
résultats préliminaires les airs sur la
chloroquine en chine sont pas du tout
démonstrative
donc il va falloir hélas cette passion
merci beaucoup
docteur alexander rappelle que vous êtes
entrepreneur et essayiste et on en vient
à cette polémique en france le manque de
masques et plus généralement de matériel
de protection certaines usines
réorientent leur production comme la
société dagoma elle a décidé de
fabriquer des visières avec son parc
d'imprimantes 3d une manière de
participer à l'effort collectif
reportage caroline béhague et grégoire
d'auxerre répondre aux besoins de
l'urgence sanitaire spécialisée dans la
fabrication d'imprimantes 3d
l'entreprise d'algoma a totalement
changé sa ligne de production habituelle
depuis quelques jours cette société de
la métropole lilloise mobilise désormais
tous ses outils de production pour
élaborer des vizirs de sécurité notre
travail quotidien
parce que d'habitude les machines qui
sont derrière moi elle fabrique des
imprimantes 3d on n'était plus du tout
notre travail de fabriquer des
imprimantes 3d on est focalisé sur la
fabrication d'hier donc c'est notre
appareil de production c'est notre
boutique production qu'on a mis au
service du pauvre il aujourd'hui est au
service des gens qui ont besoin de ce
proche
hélas hélas goma depuis maintenant
quelques jours on en produit plus de
1000 par jour et on va monter encore la
cadence de production pour arriver à
20000 par semaine dago m'avancer visière
à prix coûtant à moins de deux euros
l'unité
une manière pour l'entreprise nordiste
de participer à l'effort collectif
ils nous ont fait la commande des
hôpitaux des cliniques des pharmacies
des entreprises qui sont au contact des
clients et du public qui ont besoin de
se protéger ou pour ceux des leurs
salariés voilà en fait t'es toutes les
personnes qui ont un besoin de se
protéger aujourd'hui peuvent trouver une
solution sur notre site internet
aujourd'hui on a plus de 17000 visière a
livré dans le temps le plus des
commandes et toutes les heures
il ya des commandes qui arrive donc à un
réel besoin et nous faisons le maximum
pour pouvoir livrer tout le monde le
plus vite possible à si le produit n'est
pas homologué c'est la stratégie du
mieux qu rien à prouver par des équipes
médicales qui est mise en avant et ne le
sera pas je m'explique
c'est une ville fière de protection
s'étend c'est un moindre mal c'est un
meilleur mieux mais ce n'est en aucun
cas un matériel qui est médicale qui est
homologuée
pourquoi parce que les composantes nous
utilisons ne sont pas des composants de
graver les dix cas là d'accord
néanmoins il vivait à absolument
fonctionnel et pour en avoir discuté
avec beaucoup de médecins
c'est mieux de se protéger que de ne
rien avoir une initiative bienvenue en
cette période de crise sanitaire
alors que les critiques pleuvent sur le
gouvernement français
pointée du doigt en raison de la pénurie
de masques médicaux et dans quelques
instants nous partirons en italie qui
prolonge au moins jusqu'à pâques le
confinement de la population m et
réfléchit aussi à la stratégie pour
faire repartir le pays après la crise
sanitaire et puis direction les états
unis où près des trois quarts des
américains vivent désormais confiné le
président donald trump demande à ses
concitoyens de se préparer à des
semaines très très douloureuse rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
l'hiver est la période à laquelle le
sahara rené est les palmiers des oasis
sont l'objet de récolte les gens
attendent l'événement le plus important
de l'année
le festival du désert n'est cette
compétition est très dur
les principaux chameliers ont passé
l'année à se préparer pour un marathon
éreintant
la veille de la course une forte tempête
de sable se lève
faire face à la puissance de la nature
est un défi permanent
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france il est
20h30 20h30 heure française cette
émission largement consacrée à la crise
du coronavirus dans le monde à l'europe
enregistre aujourd'hui plus de 30000
morts depuis le début de l'épidémie le
royaume uni totalise plus de 500 décès
en une journée seulement à la situation
inquiétante également en espagne avec 8
164 décès en 24 heures neuf mille décès
au total est à 95 milles personnes
contaminées et puis sachez que la
turquie a envoyé du matériel médical
dans le pays un avion militaire turc a
décollé aujourd'hui d'ankara avec des
blouses des masques et du gel hydro
alcoolique il se rendra ensuite en
italie elle la situation en italie
toujours aussi préoccupante on le
rappelle un c'est le pays le plus touché
en europe
le bilan est lourd 13 1113 1155 morts
dont 1 727 en 24 heures et plus de 110
1574 contaminés et le confinement
pourrait être prolongée jusqu'au 18
avril à mai après trois semaines
d'isolement des signaux encourageants ce
pouvoir a mais les autorités appellent à
la prudence et le personnel médical est
toujours sur le front
lorsqu'un patient doit être transférée
aux soins intensifs
cela signifie que sa situation est assez
critique nous essayons de les rassurer
un contact vaut plus que des mots elles
savent aller moins pudique walkie j'ai
toujours été préoccupé cependant étant
donné que j'ai un rôle de coordination
et d'organisation dans mon département
il était important pour tous mes
collègues de me voir en première ligne
et puis en lombardie la russie continue
d'apporter son soutien pour lutter
contre l'épidémie un hôpital mobile
devrait ouvrir ses portes dans les
prochains jours pour soulager les
structures locales à les détails avec
clément hospital
derniers préparatifs avant l'ouverture
de l'hôpital de campagne de bergame ces
équipes médicales russe et italienne
s'active avant l'arrivée des premiers
malades malgré le fait qu'il s'agisse
d'un hôpital mobile
il comprendra tous les départements pour
fournir des soins spéciaux aux patients
infectés par le coronavirus avec 142
lits au total
l'hôpital va accueillir ses premiers
patients début avril plus de 200
spécialistes russes et italiens
recevront et traiteront conjointement
les personnes infectées dont cette ville
particulièrement touchés par l'épidémie
de coronavirus tous les hôpitaux
normalement en activité n'ont pas pu
répondre à la forte demande causée par
l'épidémie est absolument nécessaire de
lancer ce nouvel hôpital afin d'assurer
la sécurité de tous les soignants et
patients qu'ils soient en cours de
traitement pour les sens avec la chine
et cuba la russie a été la première à
répondre aux appels à l'aide de l'italie
dont plusieurs villes de la région de
lombardie
des virologues et des spécialistes de la
guerre bactériologique ont déjà procédé
à quatorze décontamination de centres de
soins pour personnes âgées
aujourd'hui une autre maison de retraite
doit subir un traitement sanitaire le d
comme on le sait le virus reste sur
certaines surfaces ya quinze jours sur
le plastique et le métal c'est étant
donné que des personnes âgées autres y
sont particulièrement sensibles aux
virus continue à vivre dans cette maison
de retraite
il faut faire le maximum arrêter la
transmission du bac
au total le ministère de la défense
russe a envoyé par avion de transport
militaire
8 brigade médicale et 100 militaires
supplémentaires à la russie va débloquer
à 1400 milliards de roubles soit près de
16 milliards d'euros pour soutenir
l'économie vladimir poutine a signé une
loi habilitant le gouvernement russe a
introduit
un état d'urgence dans le pays parmi les
mesures annoncées une aide aux petites
et moyennes entreprises
le premier ministre a également annoncé
des mesures de soutien aux régions
russes souvent très dépendante de l'aide
fédérale afin de compenser les pertes
budgétaires et pour revenir sur l'aide
qu'apporte la russie nous sommes avec
l'eau de blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on le disait
l'italie a reçu l'aide de la russie dans
la forme d'une équipe de médecins et de
matériel c'est un signe fort comment le
comprendre
je crois que les autorités italiennes
vont se sont rendus compte assez tôt au
mois de mars qu'elle risquait de perdre
le contrôle de la situation et le
premier ministre monsieur nous était
conté s'est adressé à plusieurs
interlocuteurs et finalement d'ailleurs
le 21 mars il a eu la demie routine au
téléphone et lui a demandé son aile et
vladimir poutine s'est engagé à fournir
cette aide elle est arrivée très
rapidement à partir du lendemain
une quinzaine d'avions et léo chine gros
porteurs sont venus apporter le matériel
les camions mais le matériel aussi
médicale
et puis les médecins et les spécialistes
qui accompagne alors je crois que ça
arrange évidemment très grand service à
al ala l'italie parce que la situation
est très très difficile
bien sûr il ya d'autres pays aussi ont
entrepris d'aider l'italie où l'avait
dit tout à l'heure
cuba la chine peut-être que l'italie
n'est pas mécontente d'équilibré avec la
russie d'ailleurs la france qui n'a pas
fait beaucoup de bruit à à livrer un
milliard de 1 million par dont un
million de masques de masquer le 21 mars
précisément sur l'aéroport de fiumicino
à rome
mais évidemment la france et ensuite on
manque de masques n'a pas pu poursuivre
ce genre ce genre de fournitures alors
je pense que actuellement la situation
fait que la coopération marche très bien
entre les équipes russes et l'équipe
italienne alors la russie venus en aide
également aux états unis
vous été surpris par ce geste de
vladimir poutine vis-à-vis des
américains dans ce contexte de lutte
contre le corona virus moi non mais mes
amis oui vous savez qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes le 1er avril
et quand j'ai parlé de ça ce matin
certains de mes amis ils ont cru que je
me moquais d'eux que se faisaient une
plaisanterie de mauvais goût
donc moi je suis pas surpris parce que
bien sûr la dîmière poutine et priant
les etats-unis se parlent se parlent
très régulièrement et que la l'évolution
de la delà de la pandémie étant
tellement rapide aux états unis par
ailleurs les états unis ayant des
responsabilités globales notamment dans
le monde en matière économique il est
logique que le paddy entre alpes et le
président poutine en ai parlé et qu'il
en ait parlé pour la dernière fois je
parc c'était lundi donc avant-hier le
président trump a indiqué hier dans une
de ces innombrables conférences de
presse il avait évoqué beaucoup de
sujets avec le président poutine il
avait aussi parlé un petit peu
auparavant au prince héritier d'arabie
saoudite peut-être pour parler un peu
prix du pétrole mais il a évidemment
parlé du développement de la de la
pandémie est aussi de ce qu'il faudrait
faire après et 2,6 convenait de faire
pour éviter à un effondrement économique
est là dessus bien sûr ils ont décidé le
prétend poutine et le président trump de
poursuivre la coopération présent
poutine a proposé d'envoyer un avion
avec une aide médicale et le président
contraint à accepter cet avion dividende
symbolique parce que la quantité dette
n'est pas tellement importante mais je
crois que c'est important de marquer par
cette symbolique il y à une coopération
entre les états unis et la russie
alors on en parlait également ankara a
aussi envoyé du matériel à l'espagne et
l'italie à l'allemagne et la france sont
utilisés
ce texte le mécanisme européen qui
permet de commercer avec l'iran pour
envoyer là aussi de l'aide humanitaire
la coopération internationale finalement
elle tourne à plein régime en ce moment
n'ont pas je crois qu'elle est appelée à
se développer
ce n'est qu'à ça n'est qu'un début et je
pense que après la crise il faudra
effectivement faire des réformes qui
permettront dans ces domaines d'avoir
des systèmes de coopération
internationale beaucoup plus performant
alors en effet vous l'avez dit la
turquie a envoyé un avion militaire pour
apporter de l'aide à l'espagne et à
l'italie
et c'est bien normal puisque ces pays
sont proches du point de vue les
intérêts en méditerranée et par ailleurs
la france et l'allemagne ont mis en
marche sur niant en musique le processus
un steak qui permet d'envoyer du
matériel médical à l'iran sans passer
par le dollar sans passer par les
fourches caudines d'une autorisation
américaine puisque les américains ont
maintenu toutes leurs sanctions à
l'égard de l'iran et notamment dans ce
domaine ce qui évidemment un petit peu
surprenant dans les circonstances
actuelles fera sans doute aussi quelle
réflexion sur ce sujet un petit peu
lorsque la pandémie aura été maîtrisé
par ailleurs je voulais monter sur la
coopération internationale que le
secrétaire général de l'onu monsieur guy
thiriet sa lancée il ya quelques jours
un appel à un cessez le feu
généraliser partout dans le monde et que
finalement peut-être avec une certaine
surprise on peut constater que ça va
peut être marcher un certain nombre de
pays en syrie en libye mais aussi des
intervenants extérieurs comme les états
unis comme la turquie ont adhéré à cette
idée d'un cessez le feu généralisé pour
essayer de sauver des vies pour essayer
de sauver les populations et notamment
les personnes déplacées et notamment
tous les gens qui vivent dans les camps
de réfugiés les uns sur les autres
il a lancé un deuxième à peine le pré le
secrétaire général de l'onu en faveur de
l'afrique
il a dit qu'on allait avoir une
catastrophe programmée si on ne prenait
pas immédiatement des mesures
collectives pour aider l'afrique
l'afrique qui n'a pas les
infrastructures pour lutter contre une
pandémie de cette dimension
on voit bien que certains pays africains
commencent à être affectées
donc c'est aussi une priorité qui devra
être prise en compte et je pense que
puisque le président trump préside cette
année le g7 et il aura des initiatives à
prendre sans doute également en marge de
cette responsabilité
merci beaucoup clos de blanche maison
pour votre analyse je rappelle que vous
êtes expert en relations internationales
avec 4079 décès le bilan meurtrier aux
états unis dépasse aujourd'hui semi la
chine les etats unis sont le pays au
monde avec le plus de personnes
contaminées recensé plus de 180 189
militaire selon le site de l'université
johns hopkins et pour la maison blanche
à l'épidémie pourrait faire jusqu'à 240
mille morts dans le pays dans les mois à
venir il y a une semaine donald trump
qui imaginait pouvoir lever pour pâques
les restrictions les restrictions
adoptées pour lutter contre le
coronavirus changement de ton désormais
écoutées je veux que chaque américain
soit prêt pour les jours difficiles qui
arrivent nous allons traverser deux
semaines très dures
et puis comme le prédisent les experts
comme je le pense que beaucoup d'entre
nous le prédisent après l'avoir étudiée
si intensément
nous allons commencer à voir de la vraie
lumière au bout du tunnel
et ça va être deux semaines très
difficiles très très difficile weeks
alors l'épidémie de coronavirus une
véritable catastrophe sanitaire
planétaire mais pas seulement face aux
comics 19 c'est aussi l'économie du
monde antique est sur la sellette aux
états unis bon nombre d'américains n'ont
plus les moyens de régler leurs factures
les explications en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et où
[Musique]
e
et pour parler du système de soins
américains face à l'épidémie nous sommes
en direct depuis chattanooga aux états
unis avec anthony ravard ian logan
blogueurs politiques américains c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
anthony brian noyade merci d'être avec
nous ce soir en direct sur rt france
alors une étude a montré qu'un séjour de
six jours pour une hospitalisation pour
kobe 19 coûtent 73 mille dollars pour
les personnes âgées les plus démunies le
système de santé des états unis prévoit
une couverture de base pour autant est
ce que ces personnes aujourd'hui peuvent
être soignés dans les hôpitaux
américains comment ça se passe mais plus
important c'est que ceux qui ont des
symptômes peuvent se présenter à
l'hôpital même s'ils n'ont pas
d'assurance mais beaucoup de personnes
défavorisées
beaucoup de personnes âgées peuvent
bénéficier de medicare medicaid et
auront des allocations en fonction du
système actuel elles se dérouleront bien
à zorro effectivement de grosses
factures mais certaines personnes ne
sont pas dans le système d'assurance et
ce après une personne sont au dessus de
ce seuil des personnes des lignées et
non pas encore assez pour se payer des
assurances
donc la situation devient très difficile
alors le système de santé des états unis
à l inverse du système français
s'organisent en majeur majeure partie au
tour d' assurance privée facultative
proposés par la plupart des uns des
employeurs à leurs salariés en cette
période chômée duo confinement qu'en
est-il de l'assurance santé des employés
est ce qu'il reste couvert aujourd'hui
en cas d'hospitalisation ducobu de 19
c'est une très bonne question
quelqu'un n'est pas je ne travaille pas
c'est une très bonne question je pense
que beaucoup de personnes peuvent être
couverts par medicare medicaid et
d'autres sont concernés par un
abaissement des coûts en fonte en
fonction de la situation extrême mais
maintenant il faut payer son hypothèque
payer ses impôts et
aujourd'hui avec le virus et bien
certaines hypothèques ont été repoussées
jusqu'à des dates ultérieures c'est la
même chose avec le paiement des impôts
normalement l'échéance c'est le 15 avril
et là cela a été repoussée jusqu'à juin
ou juillet je pense donc des compromis a
été trouvé et je pense que la discussion
ne peut s'appliquer ici également
mais sans assurance effectivement pas
avoir de gros problèmes et concernant
l'organisation des hôpitaux sql et les
protocoles sont centralisées comment
est-ce que cela se passe les hôpitaux
sont différents en fonction de la région
né il ya de très grosses hôpitaux avec
des gros budgets et des petites
cliniques certaines gratuites
donc cela dépend vraiment mon habitude à
quel hôpital on se rend cela dépend
vraiment de l'endroit mais le problème
fondamental c'est que les gouvernements
fédéraux régionaux et locaux vraiment là
la main dans tous ces systèmes
c'est tout comme le système d'éducation
au niveau de l'université
lorsque le gouvernement est impliqué
alors les prix explosent on a une
certaine époque les universités coûter
moins cher et maintenant les prix ont
augmenté et je pense que c'est la même
chose avec les assurances tenté une fois
la crise passée selon vous est ce que il
va falloir mener une refonte totale du
système de santé
je pense tu leur fonte était déjà en
cours et la crise pour effectivement
accélérer le processus
c'est une très bonne question car avant
cette crise du cornât virus nous avions
l'une est certaine c'est un système qui
vous donner des amendes si vous n'aviez
pas d'assurance et je pense qu'il ya
encore beaucoup de ces affaires elle
serait d'éliminer l'implication
l'engagement du gouvernement afin que
l'hôpital soit plus plus harmonisée et
plus optimisée pour les personnes
sorties n'est recaser l'assurance ou pas
alors dans ce contexte là la russie
envoie de l'aide médicale aux états unis
après un échange entre donald trump et
vladimir poutine comment cette aide est
elle perçue dans le pays je pense que
toute forme dette est perçue
favorablement auquel viennent de chine
de russie
ça n'a pas d'importance la situation
avec la russie et l'animosité avec le
président vladimir poutine certains
résultats des deux des manipulations des
médias et les personnes ont beaucoup de
difficultés en ce moment de problèmes
avec leur travail et ont du mal à se
protéger du cul il s'intéresse moins à
ce que racontent les médias
traditionnels et c'est plutôt de se
protéger et essayer de recommencer à
travailler si c'est possible alors
donald trump rhône america first
certains pays européens dont la france
parle de réindustrialisation est ce que
au fond donald trump n'avait pas raison
sur ce point
malgré le fait que les états unis
n'étaient pas non plus préparés à cette
crise avait raison c'est certain parce
qu'il disait de mettre l'amérique à la
première plan beaucoup de nos
médicaments sont produits en chine et le
système de santé n'a pas correctement
été centralisées au niveau des états
unis effectivement se recentrer sur les
états unis et nous permettrait de mieux
gérer ce genre de crise lorsqu'elles
arriveront à l'avenir nous devrions
d'abord nous occuper d'eux
avant d'essayer d'agir au niveau mondial
alors la gestion de l'épidémie par
donald trump et elle déterminante pour
la prochaine présidentielle est ce que
l'impréparation de son administration
est déjà pointé du doigt les élections
effectivement importantes elles
arriveront en novembre et donc cela
arrivera très rapidement c'est
effectivement un point important est la
crise dulko rona virus et du système de
santé à changer la situation et sera
effectivement jugés sur la façon dont il
s'en sort il pourrait y avoir 200 milles
à 200000 morts
on espère que cela n'ira pas plus mais
si la situation se passe mieux que prévu
alors effectivement cela pourrait
l'aider lors de la période électorale
pour conclure qu est-ce qu il y à des
annonces attendues dans les prochaines
heures dans les prochains jours aux
états unis pour lutter contre cette
crise du courant d'un virus je ne pense
pas qu'il y aura de nouveau aux annonces
mans de nouveautés dans la lutte contre
le corps navires us c'est toujours la
question de la dissociation social de
l'hygiène des mains
cela fait déjà un certain temps qu'on en
parle les nouveautés potentiel
concernerait sans doute le taux de
contagion ou de décès et les rien
d'autre en termes de nouveaux d'été
sinon peut-être la chloroquine qui
pourrait peut-être intervenir à mais je
ne pense pas qu'il y aura de grandes
nouveautés
merci beaucoup anthony brian logan
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes blogueur
politique américain arrivé plus tard que
dans l'hexagone le coronavirus sévit
aussi en outre-mer c'est le cas en
nouvelle calédonie où la population est
confinée depuis plusieurs jours à
l'archipel se prépare à l'accélération
de l'épidémie précision de clément
hospital avec les images à dymagym
production habituellement bondées de
baigneurs et de vacanciers ces plages de
nouvelle calédonie sont désormais
interdites au public à plus de 17 mille
kilomètres de la métropole le
coronavirus n'a pas épargné la
collectivité ultramarine du sud de
l'océan pacifique comme en france
métropolitaine
des mesures de confinement contrer les
habitants à rester chez eux
au niveau du chiffre d'affaires déjà
grosse perte
de la cliente et je travaille dans le
tourisme donc voila c stand by grace a
globalement le ton de temps est plus
long
on se demande surtout les week-ends on
se retrouve un peu les yeux dans les
yeux à se demander qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire
la situation inquiète l'épidémie de
coronavirus rend encore plus vulnérables
des territoires très dépendant notamment
du secteur touristique et où les
capacités hospitalières sont moindres
qu'en métropole mais ces territoires
éloignés ont pris de l'avancé sur
l'épidémie dans les cliniques de
l'archipel on se prépare au maximum pour
faire face au virus
nous avons comme vous pouvez le voir
installer une zone fitr à la l'entrée de
la clinique qui a pour but de
questionner les patients qui rentrent
dans l'établissement sur leur parcours
récent voyage nos voyages contact avec
des personnes contactent qui me sont
venues hors calédonie de faire des tests
en paix ratures et ainsi s'assurer que
les passants qui rentre à la clinique
soit ne sont pas porteurs du coc vie de
l'objectif de ces mesures que la
clinique reste une zone unexpo zeo
couronna virus c'est le médipôle le
centre de référence pour les infections
à corona virus en nouvelle-calédonie qui
accueillera toutes les personnes
contaminées son service de réanimation
est pris à accueillir les premiers cas
tous les personnels soignants sont dans
les starting blocks
le médipôle est prêt dans le sens où il
s'est préparé depuis plusieurs semaines
à affronter
cette pandémie près sur l'organisation
en termes de personnel prêt sur le
l'organisation termes de moyens près sur
la gestion des soins
le parcours de soins la capacité à
recruter des lits et surtout ce qui va
compter c'est l'adaptabilité en fonction
de la pression que les malades fatale
rond fatalement exerceront sur sur le
sur le système de santé les outre mer
sont pour l'instant bien moins touché
que l'hexagone avec plus de 660 qu'à une
dizaine de décès mais la fragilité de
leurs infrastructures médicales font
craindre une catastrophe sanitaire
l'opération militaire résilience lancé
par emmanuel macron devrait permettre
d'apporter l'aide et le soutien
nécessaire aux populations ultramarines
et dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur la crise du coronavirus
en france qui compte 500 9 nouveaux
décès en 24 heures et sur les auditions
à l'assemblée d'edouard philippe et
d'olivier ferrand puis nous parlerons du
crid alerte lancée par neuf hôpitaux
européens alors gouvernement face à une
éventuelle pénurie de médicaments pour
lutter contre le govic 19 à rester avec
nous sur rt france
[Musique]
nous sommes avec philippe douste blazy
ancien médecin ministre de la santé sous
la présidence de jacques chirac
est-ce que vous ne portez pas une part
de responsabilité comme tous les
ministres de la santé de moi je fais
partie des gens extrêmement humble et
qui pensent que bien évidemment j'aurais
eu tous heures depuis le premier jour de
ma vie mieux quand on voit la gestion de
cette crise est une gestion d'urgence le
constat est plutôt catastrophique pour
un pays comme la france
lorsqu'on est dans une guerre ne
reconnaît au front biais des question
qu'on peut se poser
il ya des questions que se posera plus
tard parce que c'est une catastrophe
sanitaire comme on n'en voit jamais
personne n'aurait pu penser que nous
serions aujourd'hui moment où je vous
parle en saturation des lits de
réanimation en seine-saint-denis a quasi
saturation sur l'île de france
la seule chose qui peut compter
maintenant c'est le confinement le
dépistage et le traitement et j'espère
que tu confinement sera remarquablement
fait parce que là la différence en
confinement moyennement fait et un
confinement très bien fait c'est des
centaines de l'hydre et à la salle
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de stratégies
peuvent porter des résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
sur les chômeurs et chaque semaine dans
l'échiquier mondial nous analyserons les
coups les plus complexes du jeu
politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
si on chantait mère youba je dis quoi
les chansons d'abord guirassy aussi
moyer columbia et yoli bi djè
envoyez vos paniers honte
le soleil ou piquionne dalo guirassy
brian baloyi coda
à tours david cameron
taiana
c'est à dire voilà je chante beaucoup
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ah bon les femmes bon gars et maintenant
les femmes ce qui a été l'histoire
jusqu'à maintenant était biaisé
[Musique]
pour l'histoire de l'art d'ailleurs la
problématique est bien là pour
l'histoire de l'art c'est marginal et il
a fallu vraiment des femmes génial très
très doué pour arriver à trouver une
place dans un domaine où rien n'était
prévu pour elle
[Musique]
ces femmes artistes ne s'en sont sortis
que parce qu'elle avait les tripes
vraiment bien accroché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour une demi heure
d'information il est 21h heure de paris
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
de ce mercredi 1er avril 2020 le premier
ministre et le ministre de la santé
questionné en fin d'après midi dans le
cadre de la mission d'information sur la
gestion de la crise du coc vide 19
il est probable que le déconfinement
france ne se fassent pas en une fois et
pour tout le monde a déclaré edouard
philippe
selon le dernier bilan officiel on
dénombre en france 500 9 nouveaux décès
ces dernières 24 heures dans les
hôpitaux et un total de 4000 32 morts
[Musique]
une pénurie de médicaments c'est ce que
redoute neuf hôpitaux européens qui tire
la sonnette d'alarmé dans une lettre
adressée à leurs gouvernements
respectifs
il appelle à des mesures d'urgence
craignant le manque de curare de
corticoïdes ou d'antibiotiques
alors que la demande de médicaments
utilisés en réanimation explose en
pleine crise sanitaire d'une ampleur
inédite
[Musique]
comme chaque soir saint-jérôme salomon
le directeur général de la santé a fait
un point sur la pandémie qui secoue le
pays on dénombre en france 500 9 décès a
de plus à l'hôpital en 24 heures la
barre des 4000 morts a été franchi
autre chiffre à retenir 24 1639 malades
hospitalisés soit une hausse de 1882
personnes et plus de 6000 placé en
réanimation dont 80 âgés de moins de 30
ans à noter aussi que près de onze mille
personnes sont sortis guéris de
l'hôpital alors que les hôpitaux
d'ile-de-france sont saturés 30 6
patients graves de la région parisienne
sont arrivés en bretagne par tgv
médicalisé selon l'agencé régionale de
santé sans malades supplémentaires vont
être transférés d'ici jeudi est midi et
face au confinement les français tentent
d'échapper à l'ennui dans leurs longues
journées de confinement sports jardinage
aux médecins ils trouvent des
occupations pour certaines ingénieuse
luis carballo et mediascape en cette
période de crise sanitaire de nombreuses
personnes cherchent à gérer les
difficultés du confinement dans ce
quartier à l'ouest de lyon valentin
utilise un parking en guise de terrain
d'entraînement 40 minutes d'exercices
trois fois par semaine pour maintenir sa
forme et garder le moral
employé d'une marque de vêtements de
sport il a continué à travailler pendant
les deux premières semaines du
confinement
désormais rien n'est sûr pour les jours
qui arrivent malheureusement de la
chance d'avoir un petit terrain d'herbe
donc ça me permet d'aller courir et de
deux fermes et exo deux fois par semaine
et après avec ma copine dans le salon on
a aménagé un peu un espace de sport avec
heureusement on a un tapis on a quelques
élastique et j'ai on a réussi à
construire des avec des sacs au chant on
a rempli de livres de bouteilles pour
faire des poids et des chars des exo
avec ça me permet de sa part être bien
commencer la journée
ça me permet de me vider la tête de me
réveiller et puis et puis oued oublié un
peu tout ce qui se passe
au troisième étage un bruit métallique
interpelle c'est l'imprimante 3d
d'arthur qui s'est lancé dans une
fabrication un peu particulière des
visières de protection en plastique
destinés à être fournis gratuitement aux
soignants dans les hôpitaux
il est à la tête d'un réseau bénévole
pour la distribution de ces masques 2.0
pour un coût de fabrication de moins
d'un euro par visière son imprimante
tourne à plein régime
moi de mon côté avec mon imprimante 3d
geprim vraiment uniquement là le support
qui est la partie blanche ici qui est la
plus complexe doit être souple et s
maintenir une connexion du coup un peu
gras de tout le visage concret là bas et
puis ma on essaie de travailler main
dans la main avec le personnel soignant
et les hôpitaux qui nous font des
retours sur valero nominee ce qui va ce
qui va pas ce qu'on peut améliorer le
confort c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas il
peut le porter toute la journée etc
plusieurs versions fonction aussi sur
encore et aux besoins d'autres préfèrent
s'aérer l'esprit et profiter de leur
jardin comme thierry auto entrepreneurs
dans la rénovation il possède un énorme
potager situé dans l'arrière partie de
la résidence tout en respectant les
règles du confinement il surveille ses
salades et ses autres plantations mais
reste perplexe pour la culture de ces
légumes de printemps c'est pour échapper
à ce musulman et d'évacuer le stress
familial qui peut y avoir dans un espace
confiné d'appartements ont fui madame
par exemple et on se retrouve dans le
calme et dans la verdure
ça permet de pouvoir un peu décompressé
sur des longues journées de confinement
entraînement physique entraide jardinage
chacun sa manière d'affronter un
confinement règles strictes une
situation amenée à durer jusqu'au 15
avril mais qui pourrait bien être
prolongé face à une situation qualifiée
de totalement inédite par le directeur
général de la santé
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire le
premier ministre edouard philippe et le
ministre de la santé olivier vers ans
sont auditionnés dans le cadre d'une
mission d'information de l'assemblée
nationale
les auditions par visioconférence avec
une quarantaine de députés et pour plus
de précisions on va retrouver devant
l'assemblée nationale notre reporter mon
âme ou dès lors un mona bonjour alors
expliquez nous quels sont les enjeux de
cette mission qu'est ce qu'il faut
d'ores et déjà en retenir cette mission
informative elle a pour but de contrôler
les décisions de l'exécutif pendant
cette crise sanitaire olivier avérant
edouard philippe étaient présents pour
répondre aux questions des députés via
vision conférence des députés de tous
les bords politiques edouard philippe
tout au long de cette mission
informative a rappelé l'urgence
sanitaire c'est une crise mondiale
exceptionnelle ce sont elles les mots du
premier ministre est une des premières
questions et c'est peut-être la question
que tous les français se posent en ce
moment quand aura lieu ce déconfinement
selon edouard philippe le premier
ministre plusieurs scénarios sont à
l'étude mais pour l'instant rien n'est
sûr puisque la situation sanitaire
évolue de jour en jour je vous propose
d'écouter d'or philippe ce qui est à peu
près acquis à ce stade c'est que nous
avons décidé du confinement en
application d'une stratégie que le
ministre et moi-même avons plusieurs
fois expliqué qui consiste à limiter le
nombre de cas sévères en essayant de
faire en sorte qu'ils ne dépassent pas
les places disponibles d'accueil dans
les services de soins intensifs et de
réanimation
cet indicateur aussi longtemps qu'il n'y
a pas de traitement prouver pas de
vaccin reste évidemment un indicateur
décisif pour le déconfinement il est
donc probable jeudi probable et j'essaie
d'être précis dans mes mots probable que
nous ne nous acheminerons pas vers un
déconfinement qui serait générale et
absolue en une fois partout et pour tout
le monde
naturellement les questions sanitaires
se sont dirigés vers olivier véran le
ministre de la santé notamment
concernant la pénurie à 2
ce que le manque cruel de matériel dans
certains hôpitaux
le ministre de la santé a livré quelques
chiffres jouent propose à de l'écouté
cette semaine pour vous donner une
indication nous avons renforcé notre
stock est de l'ordre de 28 millions de
masques donc nous avons consommé 40
millions et faire entrer 28 millions de
masques 8 millions par une production
nationale
le reste relevant de dons et
d'importation le plan blanc qui a été
activée très tôt la déprogrammation de
toutes les activités dans les hôpitaux
et les cliniques privées a permis
d'augmenter nos capacités de réanimation
à dix mille lits et nous sommes en train
de continuer à les augmenter
avec un effort c'est nominale autre
thème abordé également lors de cette
mission informative le thème de
l'éducation
edouard philippe le premier ministre a
voulu tempérer concernant cette date du
4 mai pour la reprise des cours il a
expliqué que rien n'était acquis rien n
est sûr et la situation risque d'évoluer
il en est de même pour le baccalauréat
il a expliqué qu il était l naturel que
il ne se ferait pas dans les conditions
normales vous l'avez compris tous les
mercredis l exécutif devra rendre des
comptes face à des députés de tous les
bords politiques à la levée du
confinement cette mission informative
elle se transformera en commission d'
enquête à la demande des républicains
merci beaucoup mona pour toutes ces
précisions monaco dès lors en direct
devant l'assemblée nationale et pour
revenir sur la crise sanitaire en france
et les travaux de l'assemblée nous
sommes avec un guillaume bigot
politologue et essayiste guillaume bigot
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france
alors ce soir on le disait le lancement
de la mission d'information avec
l'audition du premier ministre et du
ministre de la santé
samedi dernier les deux hommes ont donné
une conférence de presse avec beaucoup
de détails et de précision alors est ce
qu'on est en train d'assister à une
véritable transparence du gouvernement
ou plutôt un exercice de communication
est pas incompatible par la
communication en étant transparent
on peut simplement noté qu'il y a une
énorme énorme différence entre le ton
martial boire autoritarisme président de
la république
kinki
finalement tente de dissimuler
probablement une forme de conclusion et
de gemmes et le ton beaucoup plus
mesurée beaucoup plus humble aussi de
d'edouard philippe et d'olivier ferrand
alors qu'on peut regretter que le
pouvoir en général mais la critique est
aisée l'art est difficile bien sûr court
après les événements et finalement
maintenant aujourd'hui reconnaître et
c'est heureux qu'il y a eu des erreurs
et que hill on le sent bien de manière
tout à fait sincère certaine toute la
machine étatique franc pèse tout le
système de santé trop fait et l'exécutif
est mobilisé pour faire au mieux et
l'exercice consiste à rendre compte au
plus juste en plus près de manière
humble et sincère
bon c'est un exercice qui la seule chose
c'est qu'on peut dire que cette sorte de
deux malades caisses enregistreuses de
ce qui se passe on n'a pour l'instant
pas de vision sur la presse pas de cap
pas de stratégie alors qu'on ne peut pas
tout savoir c'est ce qu'a dit ce soir le
premier ministre et voir philippe parce
que justement le gouvernement a intérêt
à révéler ses failles notamment pendant
dans cette commission
pendant cette mission oui je pense qu'il
a un intérêt deux raisons la première
part que tout va finir par se dénouer et
ce savoir et et qu'en réalité le seul
intérêt à ne pas jouer cartes sur table
c'est jeudi le seul intérêt de ce prêt
de maintenir une certaine forme ou de de
confiance mais si on réfléchit bien le
lien de confiance et l'autorité de
l'état et de toute autorité d'ailleurs
dans sa parole est lié ou à
l'établissement de cette confiance au
maintien à l'entretien fait confiance or
si on ne sent pas finalement une parole
d'autorité peut consister à dire est que
les nous ne savons pas tout et pour pour
les préfets d'entendre des dirigeants
dire on ne savait pas tout alors que
tout le monde voit bien qu'ils ne savent
pas tout et qu'il se sont envoyé ses
matinées faire des arrières les
commandes par milliards donc il était
temps de le reconnaître mais c'est une
parole finalement rassurante
en réalité je pense que c'est un réflexe
un peu corporatiste la haute fonction
publique aux manettes à la tête de
l'exécutif depuis très longtemps en
france c'est un réflexe corporatiste
il tend à considérer que coop est un
grand enfant on doit pas pu lui dire
pour leurs assurés d'une certaine façon
et ce n'est pas rassurant du tout donc
paradoxalement ils avouent leur
ignorance qu'ils avouent leur ligne et
au contraire à mon avis extrêmement
rassurante
on a vu aussi des dirigeants français
beaucoup consulté les experts a
notamment au début de la crise à ce que
c'était une bonne stratégie de la part
du gouvernement selon vous non et à
nouveau pour dragon du temps la première
est que les experts ne sont jamais
d'accord entre eux il ya un philosophe
elle gaston bachelard qui a beaucoup
réfléchi à l'histoire défiance et avec
cette formule la vérité est une suite
d'erreurs rectifier la vérité
scientifique est une étude est rectifié
vous ne trouverez pas 2 d'experts ils
sont d'accord entre eux
donc quand bien même vous voulez vous
reposer sur la parole des experts l
expert arte l'expert besset d'experts
qui dit qu'il faut laisser faire
l'immunité comme en grande bretagne
c'est l'expert libye pour compiler on
sait l'expert public il faut pratiquer
les têtes
donc c'est bien nos politiques de
choisir c'est d'ailleurs la raison
d'être profonde des politiques il y
avait un pilotage automatique autant
laisser loeb du pasteur dirigée la pente
n'était pas possible
la deuxième raison fondamentale et que
finalement il s'agit toujours dans ce
réflexe un peu technocratique
corporatiste des les gens qui nous
dirigent de se cacher derrière une
autorité au dessus alors à la fois pour
ouvrir un parapluie on se convainc bien
sûr pas nous qui avons des piliers tels
comités d'experts et aussi parce que
finalement cette classe dirigeante
mettons les guinéens et hellip les camps
et guinée elle a été sélectionnée forme
et non pas sur des critères de décision
politique n'est précisément tous les
critères de gestion et d'administration
un administratif un gestionnaire fait
quelqu'un il a rapporté à une autorité
supérieure c'est quelqu'un qui va se
fonder sur des précédents et qui va
chercher finalement une solution qui
existe déjà mais précisément ces papas
la politique la politique c'est faire
face à l'imprévisible faire papale
implantables et quand il ya un président
y est allé d'un portable précisément il
n'y a rien dans les manuels
il n'y a rien dans la gestion n'y a rien
on les précédentes pour traiter le
problème
alors du coup en quoi cette crise
finalement va changer le rapport des
français à la politique selon vous le
point de manière assez forte
elle va aboutir à un changement de
plaques dirigeante
parce que d'abord il ya des raisons des
répliques reconduit
thione jolivet tout à l'heure il ya
vraiment une dimension de gestion et à
la fois la haute fonction publique un
l'ena et tout ça mais c'est aussi
finalement un paradigme un modèle qui
est le modèle anglo-saxon du management
qui a été complètement digérée par
l'énarchie française et est ce modèle de
management
que dit il il ne faut pas faire de
stocks le just in time
il faut toute la produire en chine parce
que ça coûte moins cher fait la
rationalité fait les modèles économiques
ont attendu ce modèle économique dit il
encore
eh bien il dit finalement que l'économie
doit tout driver doit tout diriger et
donc on voit bien ce système en tête
prend l'eau de toutes parts l'arrivée de
rob ça a été suffisamment suffisamment
dit et répété mais finalement l'élément
le plus stratégique éléments le prix
politique dans le couple edouard
philippe emmanuel macron c'est tout de
même l'idée de faire ce sont vers une
dimension telle ayral vers constituer un
état européen est d'ailleurs le
président n'en démord pas finalement ça
ne fonctionne pas mais le président veut
aller encore moins dans le rock ce on
voit bien qui a une monnaie il n'y a pas
de budget il n'y a pas d'état il n'y
aura ni budget ni l'état parce qu'il
n'ya pas de peuple
merci beaucoup guillaume bigot d'avoir
partagé votre analyse rappelle que cette
politologue et essayiste nous risquons
de manquer de médicaments pour soigner
les malades du coronavirus c'est le cri
d'alarmé lancé par neuf hôpitaux
européens à leur gouvernement
un courrier signé également en france
par l'ap-hp est soutenu par l'ensemble
des hôpitaux publics français et le
message est clair il est urgent d'agir
pour éviter une tragédie
explications en images
[Rires]
[Musique]
et pour parler de ces médicaments
indispensables à la lutte contre le coc
vite 19 et qui pourrait bientôt manquer
nous sommes avec frédéric bizarre il est
économiste de la santé enseignant à
sciences po et président de l'institut
santé frédéric est bizarre merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
depuis 25 ans la france c'est un des
premiers pays producteurs de médicaments
l'union européenne elle est même un des
premiers exportateurs mondiaux
comment peut-on arriver à une telle
situation de pénurie dans les hôpitaux
français
alors c'est vous avez raison on a été le
premier producteur européen pendant
longtemps mais nous avons perdu cette
première place
sur les dix dernières années puisque
nous sommes maintenant numéro quatre en
europe
donc nous nous avons laissé un petit peu
filer notre souveraineté sanitaires sur
le plan des médicaments n'aimait pas
uniquement sur le plan des tests y
compris sur le plan d'équipement très
basiques comme les masques ou la vue
coup qu'on a véritablement des
difficultés d'approvisionnement donc ça
c'est le premier point c'est que nous
avons énormément perdu parce que nous
n'avons pas fait de la santé le
l'élément stratégique le thème
stratégique des politiques publiques
donc nous nous allons laisser filer un
petit peu notre notre leadership en
consentez c'est vrai pour la production
industrielle c'est aussi vrai pour les
services de santé on a eu cette ce
classement de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé 2000 qui nous a mis en première
position mondiale
champion du monde en 2000 et et on s'est
un petit peu reposé sur ses lauriers
mais entre temps le monde a
considérablement changé il ya cette
triple transition épidémiologique
démographique et technologique qui fait
que si vous vous adaptez pas c'est un
processus darwinien
eh bien vous vous perdez en
compétitivité très rapidement et c'est
ce qui nous est arrivé
alors pour revenir sur ce risque de
pénurie l'alliance des hôpitaux
universitaires européens a dit avoir
déjà alerté un les gouvernements depuis
le
la semaine dernière en vain comment est
ce qu'on peut comprendre ce manque de
réaction
alors ça c'est assez facile à comprendre
pour voter pour vos téléspectateurs
c'est c'est assez propre à une épidémie
c'est que l'épidémie contrairement à
toute autre pathologie est un processus
exponentielle qui fait que si vous
n'êtes pas prêt avant le début de
l'épidémie
et si vous ne prenez des dispositions
que lorsque cette épidémie est arrivé eh
bien vous êtes dépassés par la vitesse
de propagation et donc par là la vitesse
de demandes que ce soit aux médicaments
on lit de réanimation ou en offre de
services vous vous êtes dépassés parce
que c'est un phénomène exponentiel donc
on a là en europe aujourd'hui une
demande extrêmement forte pour les mêmes
produits qui ne sont pas partis des
produits de ce qu'on appelle la réserve
stratégique donc pour lequel il n'y a
pas de ya pas de stocks abondants et
donc tous ces pays se retrouvent à peu
près un même niveau de maturité de
l'épidémie et donc avec un et une
demande qui est qui explosent ou pour
les mêmes produits pour cela il n'y a
pas besoin d'être économiste pour
comprendre que forcément il ya un goulot
d'étranglement et que et que l'offre de
de production n'arrive pas à faire face
il faut savoir que juste pour cette
production
là les deux tiers des principes actifs
de l'ensemble des médicaments qui sont
produits pour l'europe et pour le reste
du monde proviennent de l'asie est donc
là aussi l'europe n'a pas véritablement
pensé de façon stratégique à sa
souveraineté sanitaires et à laisser les
producteurs les mieux disants en matière
de coûts prendre le contrôle de la
source de leurs médicaments ce qui est
qui qui sont ces principes actifs et
donc là on en paye du coup du coup la
réponse au problème
elle n'est pas forcément européenne non
non la réponse à ce problème là lé pac
européenne elle est mondiale mais
aujourd'hui vous avez une pandémie qui
touche près de 150 pays
donc vous vous imaginez la problématique
à partir des pays asiatiques qui font
aussi de la géopolitique n'oublions pas
que évidemment il ya tout
de la politique derrière derrière ça
lorsque les chinois nous approvisionnent
en prenant en tel type de produits otc
il ya forcément un jeu politique qui
fait que nous approvisionnent mais pas
suffisamment et donc vous êtes demandeur
et vous restez quand même dans une
position du demandeur dans une position
de faiblesse politique et ça clairement
c'est le sait ce que paye l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas avoir
garanti alors qu'elle en a tout à fait
les moyens sur le plan n'oublions pas
que l'europe était quand même le perso
de la médecine pendant des années
pendant des décennies et a laissé filer
ce leadership là et là je crois que
c'est une leçon dont il faudra tirer
toutes les conséquences et du coup en
cas de réquisition des moyens de
production comme comme le demandent à
l'alliance des hôpitaux européens est ce
que vous pensez que la france pourrait
produire suffisamment pour soigner ses
citoyens malades alors produire
suffisamment non sur l'ensemble des
besoins aujourd'hui à l'échelle
européenne lorsqu'il faut d'abord savoir
c'est que on a quand même en france
parce que bon on a quelques difficultés
quand même un petit peu de coordination
entre les différents secteurs public
privé
il faut savoir que cette épidémie à
l'échelle française elle touche de façon
très hétérogène l'ensemble des régions
si vous prenez il ya certaines régions
qui ont une capacité est encore assez
importante qui garde ses produits qui
peuvent manquer dans d'autres régions
parce que évidemment crs et régions
aujourd'hui peu touchés peuvent être
davantage touchés de match mais à
l'échelle du pays
nous ne sommes quand même pas face à un
risque imminent de pénurie de produits
stratégiques
hormis les produits de protection dont
on a dont on a parlé hormis les produits
de dépistage mais concernant ces
produits hospitaliers
il n'y a pas de risque imminent en
france sauf si évidemment cette épidémie
prenait une ampleur équivalente parce
que nous avons aujourd'hui en ile de
france ou dans le grand test sur
l'ensemble du territoire
mais c'est pas le cas et en tout cas les
chiffres montrent que pour le moment ce
n'est pas le cas merci beaucoup frédéric
bizarre
d'avoir partagé votre analyse sur notre
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste de la santé enseignant à
sciences po et président de l'institut
santé et puis nombreux sont les acteurs
mobilisés durant cette pandémie de covin
19 soucieux d'apporter leur pierre à
l'édifice durant ce combat elle c'est le
cas de ben hélas un agent de
tranquillité à la mairie de nanterre
tout de sensibiliser la jeunesse au
confinement et aux gestes de précaution
un sujet de cynthia lauvergeon et
nicolas winckler bon copain qu'est ce
que tu fais ce que tu fais je vais faire
du sport
j'en ai besoin pour me dépenser parce
que je vois pas rester à la maison je
peux pas là mais s'est classé alors j'ai
ma carte d'identité si vous voulez je
vous la donne on nous raconte
restez chez vous c'est le message que
s'attache à faire passer ben et lassana
médiateurs de rue en cette période de
pandémie de covile 19 la mairie de
nanterre tient à maintenir la présence
active de ses agents de tranquillité
publique
objectif sensibiliser la population
confinement et mesures de sécurité sont
nécessaires conscience du phénomène
ils savent que c'est dangereux ils ont
tous des téléphones il voit même la
fonte même si vous voulez pas les
regarder la télé sur le téléphone les
infos donc ils voient que les morts ils
voient que c'est par jour pour un skieur
s'est passé donc m'amener on va dire
même les gens qui sont d'habitude peu
récalcitrant est pas pris conscience que
il ya un réel danger et que c'est pas
n'importe quoi ce qu'ils veulent mise en
place depuis 2005
cette brigade est au coeur de la ville
ben et lassana investissent des lieux
publics repères n'est situations à
risque règle des conflits et neutralise
détention éducation scolarité
délinquance juvénile ou encore exclusion
sociale sur leur terrain d'action
nanterrien de naissance ben et lassana
jouissent d'une certaine légitimité
auprès des jeunes de la ville connaisse
une grande gêne et nous on est d entre
eux nous ont beaucoup causé aussi est
aussi sympa je préfère que ceux qui
viennent nous voir conduire de préférant
de vrai que les uniformes bleus le
rapport avec avec la population c'est
pas le même que celui de la police comme
annoncé c'est différent c'est différent
d'où on vient on est des frères on est
nous connaissent avec la veste et sans
veste
on a aussi du quartier on est du
quartier d'ailleurs ce service il a été
créé aussi avec la majorité avec des
personnes vivantes dans le quartier
de nanterre dans les quartiers
populaires de nanterre si les choses
peut s'arranger de manière humaine comme
cela est écrit ci tranquillité manière
tranquille ça suffit la brigade de lutte
contre les incivilités est l'une des
fiertés de la mairie de nanterre
pionnière dans ce combat pour renforcer
le lien social et le sentiment de
sécurité des habitants carlos lourenço
directeur de la tranquillité publique
travaille depuis une douzaine d'années
au sein de cette escouade que patrick
jarry maire de nanterre s'attache à
maintenir sur le terrain à aucun moment
le maire de nanterre n'a pensé à
l'arrêter nous non plus au contraire on
a plutôt tenté de l'intensifier on à
l'aide d'un certain nombre d'agents
d'autres services d'agent des sports par
exemple d'agents des services de
jeunesse qui viennent nous aider et paul
et nos équipes pour quadriller la ville
et pour pouvoir diffuser ce message
auprès de la population
malgré la pandémie ils sont 24 agents à
tous les jours arpenter les rues pour
rassurer les nanterriens nous on est là
pour vous dire faites attention à vous
n'oubliez pas votre masque les gore a et
l'alcool ok et les distances de sécurité
visée la fin de cette émission un peu
écourtée en raison du coronavirus et
comme tous les médias nous sommes donc
contraints de réduire nos programmes
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
ce sera demain à 9h bon courage à tous
et très bonne soirée sur rt france
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
je m'appelle zhongxing via j'ai 18 ans
je crois en effet d'entraînement
on va leur enseigner leur show c'est
l'école d'arts martiaux du temple de
shaolin
et le ça fait trois fois que je te le
dis tu ne comprends pas où tu vas
t'entraîner tout seul
[Musique]
encore une fois c'est pas bon comme si
c'était la première fois en jetons à se
tourner encore les filles le font mieux
croire en toi et tu réussiras
[Musique]
ça
la société afghane ne permet pas aux
femmes d'être libres comme les hommes
les hommes peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent mais pas les femmes
[Musique]
nous avons encore besoin d'un garçon en
tout cas j'ai sept filles et pas de fils
[Musique]
en fait seuls les pies qui viennent chez
nous et qui joue avec elles savent que
c'est une fille dehors quand elle joue
avec une balle
personne ne se rend compte que c'est une
fille et tout le monde croit que c'est
un garçon
[Musique]